hello and welcome to footnotes as per
the usual I'm here to recap the most
ravishing ideas from around wired first
up today caffeine the only drug you can
make it work unless you work in a meth
lab in which case it's one of two drugs
you can make wired business reported on
a new service called lab door to test
energy drinks to see if they contain
dangerous ingredients like chemicals
that give you giraffe legs the caffeine
and these energy drinks is actually
extremely toxic if you happen to be an
insect which is fine because you're
gross and nobody wants you around anyway
this is because caffeine involved in
plants as a pesticide that causes
insects to get really chatty and go to
the potty a lot legend has it that
humans discovered the wonders of coffee
in the 15th century when a goatherd in
Yemen noticed that his animals were
acting like idiots after eating the
plants berries on the other hand we
started drinking tea over 10,000 years
ago in China though goats were not
involved in its discovery because they
were only invented in the 13th century
and if for some reason we were wondering
if spiders enjoy caffeine like humans do
you're not alone strangely NASA once set
out to test drugs on the arachnids and
while on caffeine the spiders were
ridiculous webs but on LSD the webs were
almost normal which means that someone
needed to get those spiders and more
acid next up Mickey Mouse friend role
model murderer game I've reported on
Disney's shutting down the studio that
developed the game series Epic Mickey
which means you'll just have to pretend
to be Mickey like the rest of us by
getting a job at Disneyland so Walt
Disney created Mickey in 1928 basing him
on a previous character called Oswald
the Lucky Rabbit you see Walt had lost
the rights to Oswald when he left
universal studios and that isn't very
lucky at all interestingly 80 years
later no joke Disney twitted
sportscaster Al Michaels to Universal to
regain the rights to Oswald in the
biggest metaphorical middle finger ever
given to a human being so after the
split with Universal in 1928
Disney created a Mickey Mouse short
called plain crazy which Mickey tears
off a turkey's butt and attaches it to a
plane that milks a cab that's holding
onto the back of set plane and finally
creeps out Minnie Mouse so much that she
decides to leap from the aircraft but
this would not be the first official
Mickey Mouse release that famously was
Steamboat Willie the issue with
Steamboat Willie is that compared to
plain crazy it's plain not crazy Mickey
plays a goose like a bagpipe or some
silly crap and that's a problem it's the
bland Mickey we've known for almost a
century and as charles bukowski once
noted his popularity should horrify us
he's cute sure but also stupid and
vacuous and teaches our children
absolutely nothing except how to kill
bugs not with caffeine but with murder
sweet delicious murder